Perfect timing.
I think my settings are strange.
Can you hear me?
Null.
Yes.
Bad and clear.
You guys!
I might have done something silly.
Takezo, thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
And I got influenced.
But...
What did you do?
So I saw a video of a person that was like, Look at this tiny monitor.
And I was like, It's so tiny!
It's so cute!
And...
Logan, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
And so I...
Maybe it was just like, I want the tiny monitor, but I have no use for a tiny monitor.
And then I was like, Wait a second.
I could put chat on the tiny monitor.
Belated White Day, thank you so much Brian.
Not unwritten.
And so...
Wait, you guys can't say though that I hate you guys.
Because I literally bought a tiny monitor.
Just to put you guys on the tiny monitor.
So now you have your own little dedicated space.
She trapped us.
No!
No, no, no.
You're in a good position.
Oh gosh.
Don't put us on the tiny monitor.
What's wrong with the tiny monitor?
But also...
Astrobot speedrunning community?
No way.
Thank you for the super chat.
One of those digital photo breaks that goes through his profile picture.
No, so I...
It might take me a second.
I told you guys this because it might take me a second to get used to it.
But right now it's working.
Amazon has free returns.
I like it.
I like the tiny monitor.
But here's another thing.
Here's another thing.
When I travel...
Taking my monitor...
Or taking my laptop plus a whole other monitor is so heavy.
And instead now...
I could take the tiny monitor.
I could take...
What if I got a tiny desktop and then I have a tiny monitor?
How big is it?
It's like...
I don't know.
It's really tiny.
It's...
It's really small.
Hold on, I'll take a photo.
I'll take a photo.
Sorry kids.
Wait, I don't think I would be able to show you right now though.
Because my one monitor is set to Astro Bot.
What did you say your name was?
Astro Bot.
My voice is terrible today.
What's happening?
I have to really heal my voice up though.
I have stuff I need to record soon, you guys.
I'm gonna be taking it easy with my throat for a bit.
Look at this.
I am Astro Bot.
The wish box is kind of cramped, boss.
No, it's not!
And it's...
Okay, I'm gonna...
Hold on.
I'm gonna post it to Twitter.
Okay, hold on.
Let me take a photo.
Let me take a photo and I'll post it.
Can I have a mother base happy birthday to relieve some of the existential dread of being 35 and not owning a home.
Except for the tiny monitor.
How do I say your name?
Gus?
Gus.
Gus!
Happy birthday!
Okay, I'll sing you happy birthday then I'll post the photo.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Salutation.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday, tiny monitor and you.
Happy birthday.
Okay, I'm taking a picture.
I'm gonna wink for the photo.
Okay.
Now I'm gonna put a filter on it so I don't look so ugly.
Say wong!
Yeah, man.
Photo.
Oh, I have to cover this up.
Wait.
Hold on, I gotta take another photo.
I have something in there that's incriminating evidence.
One second, I have to take another photo.
Okay.
Everybody say cheese!
Say cheese!
You're on the photo.
You're on...
Say cheese!
Cheese!
Okay.
Let's see.
Why did I capture SigmaTub saying help?
You son of a bitch.
It's cute in the tiny monitor.
Please.
You like it.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
Astro Bot.
Okay.
I look...
I'm making a funny face.
Hold on, I'm gonna put something over me.
I'm gonna do what the Japanese girlies do and put like a little thing over your face to hide your face.
I'm making a silly face.
There we go.
I'm uploading it to Twitter right now.
You guys can tell me about my tiny monitor.
Right.
My tiny monitor I use for chat.
Another birthday.
Hold on.
Congrats on Kojima-san.
Okay.
I'm kind of scared about that.
You guys know that that's not actually Kojima, right?
I actually went back to the post today.
And I saw how many likes were on it and how many people were like, Yo, Mint, you got Kojima to notice you.
That's not Hideo Kojima.
There were actually a lot of people.
I couldn't tell.
Okay, I'm posting it now.
I couldn't tell if they could tell or not.
He doesn't even look like him.
No, that is not Hideo Kojima.
Can I get a happy birthday and a quick shout out to my friend Rhyme.
Hey, Rhyme, shout out to you from JK.
It was Kojimbo.
What?
Oh, I'm already seeing issues with my tiny monitor.
I think I might have to rethink this.
I
think I might have to rethink this.
Real Kojima doesn't look like Kojima.
Oh, Jay, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Jay.
Happy birthday.
Has anyone else's Twitter been really weird?
Like, it takes forever for me to post anything.
It takes, especially like photos, it takes like super duper long.
Thank you.
It's been like that recently.
Nah, stuff isn't loading, it's so bad.
Stupid website.
The tiny monitor will be posted eventually.
Eventually, eventually, eventually.
Eventually.
Oh yeah, because of the DDoS, whatever.
Just sell the site already, please.
Can we go back to actually it being Twitter?
Twitter?
Anyway, we're not here to talk about that.
We're here to Astro Bot.
It's been a while.
It's been a while since we've seen our little guys, so let's go see how they're doing.
And look, I'm a soup.
Recovering from jet lag.
Drinking melon soda.
Yummy.
Welcome back, Jay.
Thank you for the pink.
I wanted to do something for his... Wait.
My friend is a big fan and is getting married to his fiance.
I wanted to do something for his bachelor party as best man I thought to ask you for a special message.
Does he mind having little screaming Astro Bots in the background?
Does he...
Does he mind if I like...
They're all... They're very noisy.
Maybe he's a big fan and that's a bonus?
Okay.
I hope he's an Astro Bot hater.
No!
It's the kids?
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Here's our message for...
For...
Nate!
Hello, Nate.
Your friend, JMDelarosa94, told me to send this message to you.
Because you're getting married to Mariah.
But probably not Carrie, right?
I'm confirming with the staff off screen.
Not Mariah Carrie.
I hope you don't mind Astro Bot.
When you guys have kids, then they'll want to play this game.
And look how many of your children there are.
Also, Mariah, hit me up, girl.
Congratulations!
I hope
that worked.
Did you guys see the tiny monitor yet?
It still hasn't uploaded.
Okay.
Well, we have another galaxy.
Vicious Void.
But...
Before we go there, we must check in on our children.
Our children.
Happy birthday!
Not the bones.
I don't have those.
Ildaran.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Ildaran.
Happy birthday!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Todokete?
You're two?
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Todokete.
Happy birthday.
Thank you for the super chat, Chanchan.
Okay, I'm making sure I didn't miss anything.
I have to scroll up a lot on my tiny monitor.
It was sent!
My tweet was sent!
Do you guys see it?
Do you guys see the tiny... Go to Twitter.
Go to...
At Minto Phantom.
Do you guys see it?
You can see it next to the mythical block.
It's so cute though, right?
It's my tiny monitor.
It's not too tiny.
Don't you dare insult him like that.
Don't you dare insult... Oh look, you killed Astro Bot.
He died of your cringe.
Don't insult my tiny monitor.
Please.
He can't handle it.
He can't handle this anymore.
It's not your birthday.
Happy not birthday.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Just
killed that person.
Died of cringe.
Let's go say hi to our favorite people right here.
Hello.
Hello Raiden.
Hi Psycho Mantis.
Hi Snake.
Hello Gray Fox.
Hi other Snake.
Thanks for the 15.
Oh, 15.
I thought it said 15.
Oh no, my monitor is not tiny.
I can read it.
The 5 gifted.
Thank you.
I can read it.
It's okay.
Set us free.
You are free.
I give you guys the best place to live.
Why don't you like it?
For once I was like, oh my gosh, they are going to be so happy that they have their own little...
Their own little area.
I thought of them.
I thought of them so much that I...
That I bought a tiny monitor just so I could see them.
And then everybody is complaining.
I didn't think you would hate it.
This is a prison.
You can't see.
Yes I can.
I read your chat just now.
I can see.
We are birds in a cage.
What if I turn off the tiny monitor?
If you love something, let it go.
And if it loves you back, it will...
If it loves you, it will come back.
Okay, I'm going to do it.
I'm going to turn off the tiny monitor.
Happy St. Paddy's.
All you have to do is wear minto merch and they are always wearing green.
Actually I wonder what would happen if I turned it off.
If my whole resolution would be all messed up.
I'm not going to do it.
The tiny monitor.
Let's go to the vicious void.
Like when you travel.
Yeah, it will be so good when I travel.
Why do these all look so evil?
Cock-a-doodle-do.
Oh my god.
This one looks cute.
Oh nevermind.
I thought they had big ol' thrust or bust.
I think we might have to save that one for last.
Tick-tock shock.
Armored hardcore.
Wait a second.
Why do these all sound so terrifying?
Hard to bear?
It's literally dinosaurs.
Cowabunga.
I'm trapped here.
The monitor is so tiny.
Can I also give a shoutout to the speedrunning community?
Hey astrobot speedrunning community, please don't watch this.
Thank you.
Let's try the tick-tock shock.
Let's try it.
Oh my gosh, wait.
This is my thumbnail.
I think.
Oh my god, when do those stop?
Do they?
What the hell?
Oh, this is... I have the time travel.
Wait, I used it though.
Okay, I don't think I can do it in the air.
Hello.
What do I do with you guys?
Okay.
Jump.
Why is this so insane?
The music is so crazy.
Okay, hold on.
I can go.
Now!
Oh my god, I can't go.
Just kidding.
I lied.
Redo.
I can go.
Now!
Okay.
Why is the music so scary?
Alright.
Holy moly!
Look how far we have to go.
Okay, we're fine.
This is fine.
This is... This is fine.
Stop freaking out.
Hold on, I gotta text.
Yes.
Alright, I'm not stalling.
I'm not stalling or anything.
Oh, what the?
Why didn't it work?
Yeah!
Beat his ass.
Okay.
One obstacle.
Over... Over... Dive.
Dive.
Alright, this one doesn't look so bad.
Alright.
Do I need the time?
Yes, obviously, but...
There we go.
Okay, I got him.
Okay.
First try.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
No checkpoints in sight.
I...
Don't think I see any either.
Yeah.
Bellatro.
John Bellatro here.
Wait!
No!
I don't remember how to activate that thing.
Wait, how do I activate the flower?
I don't remember.
Square.
Okay.
That's what I thought.
Dang it.
It's okay.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, we got this.
Nice.
Okay, easy.
Easy peasy, everybody.
Easy peasy.
This is quite the warm-up though.
I know!
I haven't played Astro Bot in months.
Okay.
The person up here better be worth it, I swear.
Alright, back to where we started.
No worries.
I got him.
Okay.
Alright!
What's happening here?
Is anything gonna... It looks like a launch pad, no?
That was pretty clean.
That was pretty clean, huh?
It's a trap.
Nice.
Oh, no!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to decide which way I go.
Why isn't it working?
Oh my god.
Why is my time not working?
Why isn't it working?
One more.
There we go.
I was greedy.
I wasn't double tapping.
You press both at the same...
Oh, wait.
I thought you press L2 and R2.
Okay, it's only one.
It's been a minute.
It's okay.
We're gaming.
We can get back there fast.
Oh my god.
This music might drive me insane.
That was so close.
Okay.
I'm focused.
You can do this, Minto.
Thank you.
I'm focused.
Okay, next.
Okay.
Alright.
This part's scary.
This part's a little freaky.
I was right there.
Why didn't the flower go up high enough?
Why?
Okay, stop it.
I
don't think I remember how to use the flower well enough.
That's my issue.
Alright, and shoot!
That was close.
That
was my bad.
Jump before using it.
Like jump.
What am I doing?
Oh, I'm choking.
I had such a good flow before.
You know what?
It's fine.
Okay.
Alright.
What?
Oh, I forgot to freeze time.
I forgot to freeze the time.
I forgot.
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
We can get there pretty easily, I'd say.
Okay.
I think if I had a heart, my heart rate would be crazy right now.
I didn't jump in time.
Oh my god, these new levels are crazy!
They were like, oh yeah, you can only play these if you beat the game.
Okay.
Alright.
So close.
Oh, whoops.
That was so close!
That was pretty unlucky.
It's okay.
At least I remembered this time, you know?
Okay.
I like this part because I get a bit of a rest.
I get a bit of a rest before I have to continue.
Okay.
First try.
I'm so sweaty right now.
Holy moly.
I have to do this every time?
I don't want to know the leaderboard.
I don't want to know.
My PB is...
Don't look.
They don't even give you extra stuff, they're just like...
They're like, you don't get the extra gold or whatever.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh,
sorry, I was reading your thing.
Hey, Hachi.
Let's try it.
Oh, thank you!
I was trying to figure out how to get rid of the...
I forgot about the full screen.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, I can breathe.
Oh, you have so much more room for activities.
Mintobot game win.
Okay, let's try the busted one.
Thrust or bust?
You can stretch, yeah.
Oh, okay, this is the doll.
This is the...
Oh, I like this music.
This music.
Oh, I don't like these guys though.
Ouch!
I ran right into it.
I don't know why I thought that would work.
Sorry, I don't know why that got me sick again.
Nice.
Who is a good boy?
Is that what they are saying?
What the hell am I supposed to do here?
Can you still top time?
Nope.
That was only that last... Now we have the thrust.
We've got the thrust, boy.
Okay.
Nice!
This looks horrible.
This looks so evil.
That was my nickname in high school.
The what?
Wait, what?
Wait, what the heck is that guy over there?
Am I supposed to kill that guy over there?
You see him all the way on that tree branch?
He looks evil.
Okay, sorry.
I am actually stalled.
Oh, the thrust master.
No, it wasn't.
Don't lie.
The dang... The dang guy got us.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's do this again.
Alright, back to where we ended off.
The breeze.
How did it go so fast?
How do?
It splatted.
Thrust it too hard.
Been there?
Really?
I heard people say this is the hardest of the new levels.
There we go.
Just take care of that guy.
Nice.
Wow, I made it all the way across.
Okay.
How the heck do you do this part here?
I don't think there are checkpoints in this... In these levels.
I think you just... You're just left on your own.
Gotta time it.
A normal jump should work, should it?
Let's try.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Yes, it fencing.
Okay.
What is that thing over there though?
Ouch.
Dang it.
Okay.
Oh, that was close.
Holy moly.
Don't like those purple guys.
Me neither.
They're the worst, right?
Anything that spits.
At
least I got the timing on it now though.
Kind of.
A little.
Just a bit.
Sort of.
You know.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, no spitting.
Oh no, these guys...
Ouch!
Wait, what?
What happened?
No!
Did I get smacked?
Was that what happened?
I got blocked.
Shoot.
I don't like to get this... I like to take care of that guy.
So that I don't have to think about him going after me.
Ouch!
Taco smacked.
You know, there would be worse ways to go, probably.
There's probably worse ways to go.
Not everyone can say they've been smacked by a taco.
In fact, there are probably a very large amount of people that would love to be smacked by a taco.
It's true.
I'm in.
See?
M.
Jenkins is your man.
Or woman.
Whichever.
It's like, Minto, my name...
What am I getting the timing off on this floor?
It's like, Minto, my name is Man Jenkins.
Sorry.
What do you think the M stands for?
Exactly.
Are we talking backhand or fronthand?
Like, the sucker?
The sucker side?
Or the...
Or the slimy, smooth side?
I forgot the timing for this one.
I think it's when it's, like, in the middle.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
This song makes me want to do mischievous things.
This song makes me want to act up.
Alright.
Get prickled.
Unwelcome school vibes!
Cats!
Oh my gosh!
Yes!
9-0!
That's exactly what I was thinking of!
If you guys know Unwelcome School from Blue Archive, that soundtrack is exactly what I was thinking too!
Exactly!
Look up Unwelcome School from Blue Archive.
And you'll get the vibes.
It's actually kind of become like a meme song.
In fact, it's really popular on TikTok.
Which is so funny, but it goes...
Like that.
It's kind of like, we are number one.
I know, Kisaki coming to global tomorrow.
I was really...
Risky on that one.
Okay.
Alright.
This one is so hard.
Ouch!
I had it.
It was my fault.
It's while driving.
Can you... Do you know what I'm doing?
Should I read out everything that I'm doing for you?
At least you killed that guy on the way out.
So true.
We took care of his rut.
Okay.
I'm not good at timing this one either.
Gamer callouts.
Alright, I'm jumping.
I'm jumping.
I'm stalling.
I'm not stalling.
I'm...
I'm calculating.
How was the movie?
Beauty and the Beast.
It was okay.
It wasn't great.
I guess it could have been...
Better.
I didn't... Oh, I only hated that fact that they...
I didn't hate it.
I only hated the fact that they...
There was a character in the original.
And she was a sexy maid.
That was in a relationship with...
With...
Lumiere, the candlestick.
But they made her not a maid anymore.
Why would they do that?
Oh wait, sorry, I need to pay attention.
Sorry guys, I'm gaming.
I need to...
Oh my god, did you see him?
I give it a 5 because I'm old.
And I'm nice compared to my younger self.
It would be better.
5 out of 10?
Or 5 out of 5?
Okay.
Probably tried to avoid the French maid stereotype.
Maids are not controversial.
They're not.
They're not controversial.
Okay, next.
Nice!
Okay.
Alright.
So then we go...
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, okay.
Oh shoot, what do I do?
Oh, spin!
Okay, there we go.
Nice.
Alright, I remembered, I remembered.
For some reason I thought I needed a power-up for that part.
Saved, I know.
My goodness.
I don't even see the end in sight.
Where is it?
How much more does it go?
Okay.
Alright, I am stalling a little bit.
No!
Oh, thank you for the Hagitsuba!
Wait, hold on.
Now in pause, thank you!
Sharing the love today because...
Sharing the love because today is my birthday!
May I humbly request a happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Nalentosh!
Happy birthday!
Alright.
If I...
Wait, what?
Oh, you have to decide which one you go to.
If I make this, I'm going to reward myself with being able to go to the party.
We made it so far!
This level is hard.
It is!
Miss, miss, miss.
Reward yourself anyway.
I think I will.
I'll be right back.
Sorry guys.
It hasn't even been an hour.
I've been drinking so much tea tonight.
I'll be right back.
I'm so sorry.
I can't believe I'm already having to go to the bathroom.
Give me a second.
No way.
What did you say?
Miss, miss, miss.
Oh, that was you?
That was you!
Is that your actual account?
Do you go to other channels?
Or is that like a burner account?
And you're too much of a coward to use your real account to say these things, huh?
You go to other YouTubers and you're just like...
Curse of Ra.
I have seen other please pee on me YouTuber account names.
No.
What's with the gone fishing?
It's because I'm going to the little ghost's room.
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
What is it?
Still fishing?
Not even a little bit.
Mito's still fishing.
Gamer noise.
Okay, I'm going to make some gamer noises so that I...
So that I can concentrate, okay?
Okay.
I forgot to make the noises.
I made them in my head.
In my head I was like...
Dusko!
Dusko my wife!
Thank you for the... Stop it.
Also Njico, thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Oh yeah!
Why
did you... Their arms are so short!
I went
too soon!
Nevermind.
I'm a gamer.
Oh shoot!
What am I thinking?
What was I thinking?
I'm not thinking anymore.
Don't think.
Just do.
Okay Tom Cruise, thank you!
Don't think, just do.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Just jam.
My favorite Top Gun line.
You're so nasty!
I will declare my love for you and all my feelings... What are you talking about?
I will say please PM me, Phantom.
I am no coward.
Coward.
Oh my goodness.
Oopsie.
I know you guys are just kidding around, which is why, you know...
What the?
What just happened?
It's all in good fun.
Shoot.
Oh where am I going?
Oh my god.
Wait, could you like avoid it by walking on the sides?
I wonder.
I'm
gonna die.
There it is.
I knew I didn't time it.
I didn't time it.
That's my fault.
Get yourself together, Miko.
What are you doing?
What are you doing, Miko?
Get yourself together.
This is a game to you.
How did you live that?
I know.
I bought a GameShark.
I'm just gonna... We'll just do that.
Alright, once I'm ready...
Please.
Alright, nice.
There's new levels?
There are!
And they're really hard!
They're so difficult!
Yes!
Saved!
OK.
Alright, alright, alright.
It's... We were able to do this one.
Aw, man.
This part kills me though, every time.
You OK, dog?
I'm not OK, dog.
Game Genie was another cheat device.
I actually never owned any of those kinds of things.
I might be the truest gamer.
Ruby King, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Alright.
There we go.
That's the strat.
No cheats, all skill.
OK.
I
didn't even move forward even a little bit!
Oh my gosh!
Are you kidding me?
That was so close.
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh.
Too funny.
Alright.
Seem to be getting better at that one at least, I suppose.
Nice.
Random values that were not in the book.
It injected code into the run time in the game.
Freaky effects.
Oh my, how are you gonna do it?
Like that?
OK.
Alright.
I'm scared.
I'm too scared.
No, I can't do it.
I'm too scared!
Wow!
Maybe I am a gamer!
Do I bust into him or... I don't think so.
I think I have to go to the next... the other side maybe.
Oh my god.
You know you do the...
What is this?
Burst.
Wait.
No, it's bust.
It's... Is this level called thrust or bust?
Holy moly.
I think I don't like these levels!
Astrobot, you were supposed to be my game of the year.
I thought you... I thought you... I thought you would be kind to me.
Can I have you on my next Yutasha?
Oh my gosh, I would be honored!
Oh, please!
Astrobot, you sweet, sweet... He used his arms!
Did you see that?
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, he used his arms!
Wait, so I have to go back and forth?
That seems impossible, I'm not gonna lie.
Because they're gonna keep spawning, no?
Oh shoot.
There we go.
I got him.
I don't think I... I don't think I... I don't think I...
Thrust into him, because...
Then...
With all the other spikes I die, it wouldn't be any different with him.
I think I have to switch sides.
No way, this is impossible.
This is so impossible!
This is impossible!
Is that the ending over there?
Oh, I see him!
I see the little robot guy!
Come on, get my bearings.
It wasn't impossible!
Oh my gosh!
It wasn't impossible, I did it!
Holy moly!
Holy moly cannoli!
It was way easier than I thought it would be, actually.
Okay, so his thing does reach...
That other side.
Wait, why are they both awake now?
Oh my gosh, both of them reach?
No... And then that thing also flips?
No, this is so evil.
I don't know.
Hold on.
I'm trying to catch my bearings.
Maybe I make him fall asleep again and I go fast.
Don't overthink it.
I'm scared, that's all.
I'm scared.
I feel like it would be better to be on this side, no?
On that side?
Alright, here we go.
I do feel like the other side is a little closer.
I feel like it too, unless it's in the middle and it's just...
No, it's definitely towards the right side.
They wouldn't do that though, where you have to go on...
They wouldn't put the platform over here if you couldn't make it, right?
They wouldn't put the platform here if you couldn't make it.
Please turn, astrobot.
There we go.
Nice save, nice save.
Oh my god, the big guy too even!
Oh my gosh, no, no.
Hold on.
I'm trying to get timing.
Okay, next one.
I'll go.
Are you kidding me?
Please!
That was so cruel!
Are you kidding me?
Oh gosh!
There
we go, I got him.
Oh
gosh!
Okay.
I think speedrunning this level would stress me the hell out!
Like, no!
It would stress me out way too much!
What outfit?
Oh, it's Ghost of Tsushima, right?
I picked it because of Ghost.
Alright, let's not mess this up.
Wait, timing.
There we go.
Let's go to a different planet.
We can just do a little taste test of each one, right?
I said I would save that one for last anyway.
I broke my own rule.
Oh, okay.
I'm this guy.
I don't mind this one because...
It makes it so I can be a little invincible.
Oh wait.
I become a little invincible guy like this.
I just have to roll.
What the?
Oh, that guy died on top of me.
Stupid.
Can you imagine if these were like tilt controls?
That would be so crazy.
Hey!
Stupid rabbit.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
I'm using tilt controls.
This guy is so stupid.
Oh my god, that falls.
I don't know if that's the intended...
That's intended for me now.
That's so evil.
Why would you make me jump up there?
I guess it doesn't make you jump up.
I did it.
I did it all on my own.
Not even thinking about it.
Oh, I got it.
Okay.
He just does it all on his own.
That's so silly.
That's so... It's too silly.
Okay.
Oh gosh, what am I doing?
Why am I like this?
Oh, I have to jump in the middle?
Okay.
I thought I was gonna rest my throat, you guys.
Maybe I picked the wrong game.
Here I thought we were gonna have some relaxing, fun astrobot levels.
I didn't know that they literally created hell in a game.
I saw under the water.
Did you guys see that?
Oh, I just noticed we're in Egypt.
Like I said, hell.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Literally gone pushing.
Do your worst, little guy.
He's like, I am.
Anyway.
There's no going back.
Even before this update, is astrobot really that relaxing?
I think so.
Wait, this one isn't even that long.
He's right there.
Wait, this one's not even that long.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm such a stupid head.
Sorry.
Things are in motion and I shouldn't be greedy.
I shouldn't be greedy.
Are you guys feeling relaxed right now, for real?
Oh, why did I do that?
You guys are feeling relaxed?
Like, calm you with my soothing voice.
Will that make you feel even more relaxed?
Very chill, yeah?
He turns around and walks away.
So silly.
I'm gonna be good.
I'm not gonna scream.
If I scream, I'll go...
I'll go...
You got any grapes?
Oh my gosh, wait, I do actually have grapes.
Silent screaming.
Like that.
Scream in lowercase.
Very soothing after a workday.
That's good.
Okay.
Gosh, this part is so tricky.
Wait, what?
But I was a ball.
I was a ball.
Oh my goodness.
Thank goodness.
Every time.
It's me every time.
Alright, I just have to get through this part.
And then there's a spikey and there's a bunny.
There's a couple guys I gotta take care of.
I gotta take care of some guys, okay?
Just gotta take care of some guys.
I like how this part seems fine and they're like, oh, this part's too easy.
Turn on the fire.
Oh, you thought this part would be a breeze?
Maybe speed is the key here?
Oh, I think so for sure.
It's just...
Ah, see?
I don't know how this part works.
I jump but I don't get enough air to...
Maybe like that.
What am I doing?
Oh my gosh, okay.
Jump a bit earlier.
Okay.
Oh, uh oh.
I stopped paying attention.
Uh oh.
That's no good.
Oh, he's going all the way back.
Oh, he's going back into position.
Oh, I waited way too long.
Sorry, I was reading chat.
He has nowhere to go.
Okay, we're fine.
Yeah!
Alright.
So, how soon are we talking?
Right
when you hit the side.
Like all the way here?
Oh, I think I see it.
Maybe I get it.
Okay.
Come on.
I made it!
I didn't think that guy would be able to reach me from all the way over there.
I didn't think he would reach me from all the way over there.
So cruel.
At least this level is not very long.
I was only concerned about a bunny and...
Alright, once I hit the edge.
Okay, on the other side.
I went too soon.
It's okay.
It's easy getting back there.
Oh, just kidding.
You get the idea though.
Yeah, I get the idea.
I wasn't even... I don't even think you could actually die at that part.
The part that I just died to.
That was greedy.
I'm afraid...
I will take some medicine.
I might have to cut today's stream short though.
I don't think it's the game's fault.
I'm starting to get a migraine.
I don't know why.
Usually my migraines are triggered by something, but...
I don't know.
The stress.
Did I drink enough water?
I've been drinking water.
I'll go until I can go no more.
I had a stubborn headache all day.
You know what it might be?
Oh my gosh, I went outside.
I went outside today and everything's in bloom.
I think it actually might be pollen.
I think that's it.
Because I was like, why do I feel so icky?
Oh my goodness.
That'll do it.
Don't go outside.
Not even once.
Minto touched grass.
Yeah, I had some things I had to do for my new car.
This is why I like the tiny monitor.
Outside is scary.
Alright, we're setting ourselves up.
For victory.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm safe.
Ish.
I'm safer now.
Okay.
Break that for me.
Break this thing.
It's got some animal parts inside of it.
It's got brains and stuff.
Alright.
Gosh, he...
Okay, I'm gonna have to go so fast.
Look how fast he shoots.
What the hell?
Are you kidding me?
Fall mode blocks and it dies?
Okay.
No way!
That was so horrible.
Are you kidding me?
This soul's like sure is intense.
I think I am ready for...
I'm ready for any difficult game now.
I'm ready.
I've done it.
Turn around.
Bright eyes.
Every now and then I fall apart.
Okay, don't get greedy.
Don't get greedy.
Does he only shoot in one spot or like...
Can he move around?
Okay, he can definitely move around.
Good to know.
And also, if I'm a ball, does he push me?
Yes, he does.
So if I'm on that platform, he can push me off.
I have to be very...
So let's practice here.
Okay, okay.
You can push back.
We're learning.
Yeah, with the fire though, excuse me.
And also, that other guy, we have to be able to use our arms.
Because that's how you kill him.
But I think with the... in ball form, we'll be able to...
I can't believe I didn't notice it there.
I thought it was just like a...
I didn't even notice it, like, doing that there.
Okay, alright, alright.
I didn't trust myself, sorry.
Okay.
Wait, this is not an unscrewy guy.
It's something that I have to unscrew.
Okay, interesting.
Okay, that makes a difference.
Because it's not an enemy.
Okay.
Alright, we did it.
We did it.
It's Mt.
Fuji.
Okay.
I let go just a little bit too soon.
My hand cramps with this thing, I'm not gonna lie.
Having to hold the R2 is...
You gotta have strong hands for that.
What the?
Uh-oh.
He didn't get activated.
Just in case.
Voice of an angel in the soul of an ojisan.
Yeah.
That's me.
Wait, voice of an angel?
Really?
This is a short level, mint 30 minutes ago.
We haven't been on this one for 30 minutes.
I started like...
I started 20 minutes ago.
I messed up.
I was still in the ball form though.
The fire shouldn't have killed me.
I think...
I'm starting to think that Astro Bot might be for masochists.
Game of the year, baby.
Fire should be illegal?
Yeah, I agree.
I didn't even get a single one.
I can't believe...
I was screaming.
I'm sorry.
Sorry!
So sorry.
One
day I hope to see what biblically accurate Minto looks like.
I hope she has at least 10 eyes.
This is biblically accurate.
You're seeing it right now.
You don't see all the eyes?
I got you.
There's a gap in between the pillars, everybody.
There's a gap in between the pillars.
So far that's definitely the toughest part for me.
Mind the gap.
At
least this song doesn't make me feel I'm going as crazy as the last one.
I'm sorry.
Yes!
We made it.
Oh yeah!
Sorry, I'm gonna wait.
Might have been the opportune time, but I'm...
I have to wait again.
At least I'm pretty safe here.
Alright.
Alrighty.
Okay.
Okay, Fuji-san!
Alright, I won't let go!
I won't let go!
Oh, they...
They spin around.
Oh my god.
They're right on top of me.
Okay, I'm kinda stuck.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Wait, excuse me!
I don't know if I... Stand up!
If I touch you, will I die?
I don't know.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Okay, I'm not stuck anymore.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay, alright.
Oh my gosh.
This timing is kind of insane.
Does it cover the whole thing?
Yes it does.
Excuse me!
Oh my gosh.
My finger is getting cramped so bad.
I don't know what to do!
I seriously don't.
Oh my gosh.
You got this?
I don't know the timing!
Yeah, I know I have to charge spin them.
That's what's so difficult about this.
Wait, I think I lead them over here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hold on.
I lead them here.
Alright, alright.
Okay, okay.
Lead them back over here.
Distract them.
Come here, come here.
Come back.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, it's Devil May Cry!
Yikes.
The last one we got in a minute.
This one was four.
It's okay though.
I beat it.
Oh, my finger was cramping so bad.
Holy moly!
What are you talking about?
It's those guys that were in the church in Devil May Cry 4 at the very beginning.
Those very important characters.
Duh!
Assassin's Creed!
What are you talking about?
Oh, you're talking about Snake in Metal Gear Solid 4!
Yes, yes, yes!
It is Snake in Metal Gear Solid 4.
Yeah!
I read world record instead of new record.
That'd be insane.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hard to bear.
I'm already...
How much do I have?
How much more?
This level is so crazy though.
Okay.
Oh, but if I...
Oh, my god.
Are you kidding me?
Wait, what the hell?
Oops.
What
am I supposed to do there?
Clap the hat?
Okay, okay.
I see.
I did it though.
Thank you so much for the friend!
Guys, don't ever play the extra levels of Astro Bot.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you.
Don't ever play unless you're a masochist.
And then you'll love it.
Then you'll really be so happy.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Sorry if I missed some gifted.
No,
you bastards!
I hate those guys.
Okay, I know if I...
These will move if I clap, but where will it move to?
Is it gonna topple on top of me?
I'm scared.
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you!
It's my birthday tomorrow and an early happy birthday from you.
And the wisps would make me really happy, thanks.
And really excited for the repo collab.
Thank you, Swan!
Happy early birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Swan.
Okay, time to find out.
It's not nearly as bad as I thought it would be.
Okay, I'm gonna have to jump.
Oh.
Okay.
And same here.
Don't you dare!
I hate that pumpkin man!
Okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
Okay.
Oh, don't get...
I was like, what happens after this?
I don't know, because I was a silly head.
I
thought he would just reach for it.
I thought he would just reach for it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
We got his ass.
You control what buttons you press?
Don't be a smart ass to me!
Sometimes Astro Bot reaches for things!
And sometimes he doesn't!
And it's not by my control!
Bro.
Oh, there he goes!
At least this part's really easy.
Actually, this one's not so bad.
I did press it, but I only pressed one.
Because it's kind of confusing.
Because with the other ones, you sometimes only have to press one thing.
Or you press the other thing.
Like, you don't have to press both.
But some of them you do have to press both.
So I get...
I get comfortable with only pressing one.
And I'm like, oh, I have to press two.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
My hands are so sweaty!
Ectoplasm all over my controller!
Guys, I thought this was going to be a really chill night.
What?
You stupid...
Why?
I thought these were going to be chill, cute levels!
You look like you belong in Hot Topic!
Oh, you stupid skull!
Uh-oh, my chat froze.
Hold on.
Wait, how do I refresh it?
How do I refresh it on my tiny monitor?
Let me do it F5.
Let's see.
Oh.
It worked!
Wow, that was so much easier than it's usually been.
Tiny monitor is...
is proving its worth.
It's proving its worth!
Still tiny though, yeah?
Oh, no!
Can I still clap?
Oh, please!
Please!
Okay, I got him.
I got him.
Okay, so then there's these.
And they move.
And below them is...
Okay, you can't let them drop, obviously.
Alright.
Okay.
Tiny monitor doing work.
Okay,
that area is also gonna have the walls sticking out.
Oh my gosh, wait, that part is gonna be so crazy.
How do I even get...
Oh.
Wow.
Is there like a jump platform somewhere?
How do I do that?
I can't even tell.
Clap very carefully.
How do you get up?
How do you jump up?
Around the cylinder.
Okay, sorry, I'm stalling.
I'm trying to figure it out before we go over there.
We're so close to the end, I can see them.
How far have we come?
Wow.
Oh my god.
Alright.
And they kinda like, do like a little shmoop and they're like...
Oh my god, where did this guy come from?
Okay, he's...
Oh shoot.
Okay, do I go when they block it then?
I assume.
They'll block it for me?
No, they don't.
Oh shoot.
Do I have to go to the left?
See, that's why I was so confused.
There we go.
Nice.
The other way.
That's why I was so confused like...
How do I do this?
What?
I'm a right... I'm right brained.
I'm not the creative one.
I didn't even think it could go another way.
Sorry.
I got distracted.
Correct.
What do you mean dope brained?
Oh my gosh, I got a comment on my Devil May Cry playthrough and they were like...
Wow, Mint can really pay attention to stuff and play at the same time and learn the mechanics.
She's really smart.
And I was like...
Guys, I said I was really smart.
It must have been new.
No.
I'm smart.
Why else would I have a big brained...
Emo otherwise?
Why else?
I'm a genius.
Please.
Page review.
I'm so smart.
You guys are just jealous.
Savant's the genius?
Wow.
I'm even more of a genius than I realized.
I can't fucking do this part.
I hate it.
I hate that part the most.
Please.
Die.
I
did it before.
I believe in you.
Thank you.
Screw you guys.
Maybe if I get further... Closer to here, you know.
Further.
The timing of it is so tricky.
Yes.
Again.
Okay.
We saved it.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Ah?
Oh, I think I have to jump on top of this?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh my god.
How do I do this?
I don't know, you guys.
Please.
I don't know how to do this.
Keep going left?
Okay.
How do I keep going left?
Oh my
god.
Better than the last one even.
Get me out of here.
Who was that?
I don't even know who I rescued.
What do I do?
I feel like I'm ready for...
Well, not ready, but like...
I'm a little bit more prepared.
Oh, this one is the... Yeah, this one does this.
I'm a little bit more prepared maybe for...
The final... That like level 300 level, you know?
You astro those bots.
Oh yeah.
Oh shoot, I forgot about the chain.
I forgot about the chain.
How did I live?
Crazy.
Yeah, we got his butt.
Okay, so these are little birds.
Why would they do this?
Look at the dragons.
Oh, I see it all the way up there.
I hate the aliens too.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
What the heck is going on up there?
There's spikes and then there's...
Oh my god.
And then there's spikes.
There's spikes over there.
And there's spikes on the side and spikes on the top.
Are
you kidding me?
You slide down.
Good to know.
Wow, you slide down.
Evil ropes.
Astro bots got no upper body strength apparently.
He's too slippery.
Can I?
Okay, so this is one...
If I hold down both...
I think I get the same amount as if I hold down one.
Okay, cool.
Rope covered in butter.
True, right?
Alright.
Oh no, please.
Grab it!
Astro bot!
How am I supposed to swing if I'm constantly falling down though?
Are you kidding me?
You might not be the best mid that I know.
What do you mean?
You're the best ghost mid?
What is this backhanded compliment?
Thanks, I guess.
It's fine.
I don't have to be...
the best, you know.
It's fine.
Okay, so even holding up doesn't do anything.
What?
How am I supposed to stay up?
I don't understand this one.
Can you boost after you... But I let go!
Let me try again.
Oh my gosh, my depth perception.
I just have to jump to the next one immediately?
But like, why make it look like they're little swinging guys then?
If that's not the case...
I'll try.
Okay.
Alright.
You
are the best mid I know?
Thanks.
What's
wrong with my tiny monitor?
What's wrong with my tiny monitor?
You're just not used to him yet.
Once you get to know him, he's a really great guy.
Tiny monitor.
Size doesn't matter.
Unless it's a really cute tiny monitor.
I think it's doing a really great job too.
I can read more than four comments at a time.
It's much bigger now that I enhanced the full screen.
The best mid anyone knows... Wait.
Anyone who says otherwise is lying.
Yeah.
Wait.
Senator Armstrong is the real maid because he makes a mother of all omelettes.
I'm up to six what?
Tries?
Sorry.
I don't like this part.
I don't like it.
I'm really tall.
I couldn't see.
I don't like that part.
I got past it though.
I just don't.
I didn't like it though.
I didn't enjoy getting past it or anything.
You made it though.
Yeah, I did.
Somehow.
Okay.
Maybe it's...
I was going to say it's not as bad as I thought.
Bird makes me feel so slow.
No, no, no.
I didn't have any boost.
I don't know.
But I got the strat down now at least which is pretty good.
You see, I am a genius maybe.
I need to stop saying that.
I need to stop calling myself a genius.
Genius!
Yeah,
screw you!
What do I do?
New levels?
Yeah, they put out new levels.
Just a couple and they are all really, really hard.
What am I supposed to do here?
Maybe I go past him.
Maybe I don't even beat him up.
I'm not even going to attempt trying to kill him, I think.
Boost over him.
Yeah, that's exactly what I'm going to try and do.
Dang it!
Chicken first and then laser legs.
I think you are correct.
I forgot to jump.
My bad.
Is this a reference to the MGSV chicken hat?
That would make it just that much better.
Guys, all I've been thinking about is Peace Walker.
I want to play it again so bad.
I want to play it again.
Okay, I need to stop boosting first before I laser leg.
Or I need to stop using laser leg before I boost.
Because once I'm out of laser leg, I don't get it back.
Until I'm back on the ground.
I'll have to wait DMC first this week.
Yeah, DMC Fridays and Metal Gear Saturdays.
Wait, boost first here?
Wait, someone said the opposite.
That I chicken here first and then I leg boost after.
DMCA.
Chicken then boost.
I thought boost was chicken.
Oh, by boost I meant chicken.
Yeah, maybe we'll call... Since it's too... It's kind of confusing.
Let's say chicken and let's say legs.
Chicken legs!
I hope you guys aren't hungry.
Chicken legs.
This area is so pretty though.
I'm glad that it's not on a timer.
Okay, but the game is timey.
Okay, let's go!
Oh.
Oh!
Okay, now here we go and I boost at the very end.
Okay, okay.
This is so evil.
So I'm gonna have to boost on top of him too.
You see, these are the spikes I was talking about earlier.
They're on the sides, they're on the walls.
They're everywhere.
Yeah, now two more times.
This one is so evil though because it's like...
Spitty man.
Okay, so once I get there I gotta be like...
I gotta laser leg him.
What's happening here?
Wait, what is this?
I lived?
Astrobot, your arm extends!
And you're only telling me this right now!
Sorry, I'm trying not to...
Astrobot, we could've...
And yet, you so selfishly let me have to do things over and over and over again.
Okay.
Okay, so there are two going at the same time.
No, camera please!
Camera, what are you doing?
I can't see!
Okay, thank you.
How do I talk?
When do I go?
Stop!
Camera, please!
Focus trolling.
Um...
It has to be...
Oh my gosh, I feel like I'm going blind.
When the spikes are right there on the bottom.
Because otherwise...
Oh my gosh, this is the worst!
This is the worst!
Because otherwise...
I will...
I will run into the spikes, I think.
What is happening?
Stop focusing!
Okay, I'm just gonna have to go for it.
And hope and pray.
I'll go...
Now.
I'm stuck?
Wait.
Astrobot!
What do I do?
I'm stuck.
Boost up?
Are you kidding me?
Oh my gosh, I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it.
I think I'll miss the platform.
I'll try chicken though.
Oh, it won't let me chicken.
What do I do?
I don't wanna die!
I can't hold any... Nothing works.
Nothing works.
John's happy birthday!
Sorry, I'm in a panic.
I can't sing right now.
I'm sorry!
I don't even see your super chat.
I'm so sorry.
This is why I never told you about my arm.
I'm afraid to jump.
I think I'm just gonna miss.
What's the point of saving me?
Okay.
Okay, sorry.
Slow and steady.
So much for speedrunning, Nissan.
Okay, there's a slimy man.
Alright, there's a slimy man.
We got so far, you guys.
We almost won.
We basically one-shot that area.
I wasn't even under the shadow.
Are you kidding?
I'm gonna kill these monkeys.
I'm gonna kill all these monkeys.
I'm gonna kill them.
I'm gonna murder them.
They're never gonna have families ever again.
No, I'm setting this whole land on fire!
Everything will burn.
Burn.
Burn!
Oh,
that's so awkward.
Don't lick my nose.
There we go.
I'm now Evil Minky.
I'm Evil Minky, everybody.
I'm Evil Minky and you shall only address me as such.
Okay.
I wasn't even touching the shadow.
You guys saw that, right?
I was clear.
I was clear from it.
I'm blind.
Evil Minky be like, I got you guys a huge...
I'm not laughing.
I'm laughing with my... I'm frown laughing.
I've been paid.
I can't.
I won't laugh ever again.
No, I'm not laughing.
Evil Minky be like, I'm 5'6".
I won't ever laugh again.
I'll never laugh again.
Will we make it?
I hate... I hate these guys so much.
I ran right into it.
Thank you.
I'm in public buying sourdough from the markets.
I just had to lock in and attempt to keep the straightest face because I heard the screams of the damned if I'm right here.
I'm dying.
I'm in the damned and you're laughing.
Hi, Evil Minky.
I don't love anything.
This world deserves to burn.
And if you are part of this world, you deserve to burn.
Okay, I'm done not smiling.
But I'm still evil.
Don't get it wrong.
I'm still evil.
Wait.
I'll just... I'll never... I'll never smile.
This is better.
Anyway, now this is really evil.
On a scale of 1 to evil, how evil is this?
If this was...
If this were your sleep paralysis demon...
Pure evil.
Hello.
My
blade.
It sucks because this one isn't even... This one is like...
Honestly, not even that bad.
I was doing so well.
The one part.
Go away.
Okay, so here I jump and then I boost.
Little cat going not-heh-heh energy.
I don't know how that happened.
I don't know how that happened, but it happened.
Oh my god.
Save somehow.
Does evil mean to accept marriage proposals?
No!
Evil, why cute?
Okay.
The clutch of the century.
I don't think I'm evil anymore.
Actually, we'll see if we can get past Mr. Slime and then I'll see.
I gotta get past Mr. Slime and then I'll see.
I'm scared.
Okay, it's just a pink... It's just a pink slime.
It's just a pink slime.
That was it!
That was the end of it.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
It was a single slime!
I want her to stay here instead of Turquoise Minto.
I felt so good about my victory too.
I'm never... I'm never turning... I'm never turning evil mode ever again.
I'm gonna go get some water.
I'll be right back.
Actually, I know I talked about a migraine earlier.
It's totally gone.
Let's go.
And we did four out of five.
Thruster bust.
Was I close with this one?
I can't remember.
I'm stronger now.
I've defeated... Since then I've defeated three other worlds.
I was close.
Okay, let's try it.
Let's try it.
I'm more powerful.
I don't know if I can actually get the dogs while...
When they're...
But not dogs.
The bells.
I think I just wanted to say dogs.
The bells when they're steaming.
I don't think I can.
Tofu!
Something, something.
Akasupacha, I love you.
Thank you!
I didn't have to, but thank you so much!
Thank you.
It's weird.
We used to go up and now we're going sideways.
I have to get used to it.
Do you really?
Do you really love me?
I think I should kill this guy.
I'm stronger now!
I'm so strong now!
Oh!
You guys are just like...
Hey Minto, have more confidence.
Oh you can!
Okay, cool.
Have more confidence Minto.
This is what happens when I have confidence.
Nothing ever goes in my favor.
Oh shoot.
I got him still.
Kill him.
Kill all slimes!
Destroy all slimes!
How did I miss?
It's right there!
Guys, I think I broke the game!
I think I broke the game!
I didn't know you could do that.
What the heck?
Why is the easiest part the thing that's messing me up the most?
Oh that was close.
My bad.
I was more focused on killing him.
Alright.
What the heck did I do?
Too much thrust and not enough busting.
If you break the game, that should count as a win.
Is that a speedrun strat actually?
I can't see that as a speedrun strat.
Oh my gosh!
I keep hitting the tentacle.
I already feel more confident in my movements though.
I can do this.
Maybe.
No confidence.
No confidence!
I didn't mean it!
I didn't mean it game!
Don't please!
The controller has...
The controller has a microphone.
It can hear me.
That was close.
Get out of here.
I believe you stand absolutely no chance.
Yeah!
I stand no chance!
It said nothing worked.
I have to just not think.
Tom Cruise style.
I am Maverick.
Even the spike guy gave up on...
Okay, I'm really throwing now.
What the heck is going on?
I'm making all these little mistakes.
We at Sony PlayStation like to listen in to your games and screw you over when you think you're doing good.
More like Goose how you fell into the ocean there.
I am dead, so...
Maybe I'm more like Goose than Maverick.
Talk to me, Goose.
You guys can ever say that too.
You can be like, talk to me, Minto.
And I'll beam some really...
Really cool and wise thoughts into your brain.
No, I'm right here, so I can't do it.
It has to be like a...
Like a psychological thing.
You know?
Well...
This level alone is adding content for the Minto phrasing comp.
How am I supposed to say?
This is us.
We're bursting.
We're thrusting.
We're busting.
This is literally the name of the level.
I can't...
I can't say it any other way.
I can't do it any other way.
Okay.
I'm trying to do the bust into him, so it like...
Makes him explode.
You know?
Or is this the thrust?
I don't know!
Is this the thrust or the bust?
Oh shoot.
I usually wait.
One leads to another.
Really?
So there is an order of operations?
Oh my god!
It gave me a second chance!
Kind world.
Alright, let's try and...
I missed.
How could you miss?
Alright.
I'm just gonna ignore him, like I used to before.
Not you!
You're dead.
Okay.
Talk to me, Minto starts hearing Ocelot quotes in your brain.
It's true.
Kind world.
Die.
Okay.
I don't know what's wrong with me in this part here.
This part too though.
Oh, there's so many parts that I've died on.
He's happy.
He's like, you just killed a man!
Okay, we'll go to this side.
Oh shoot, I...
I can't, I can't, I can't leggy there.
I can't leggy there or else I won't be able to make it.
Okay, I forgot about that.
I can't leggy.
Saved!
Hope you're having a fun day, stay safe.
Thank you, I am having so much fun.
Despite my mauling.
I always have fun.
You know, you can tell if I'm not having fun in the game.
I think.
Just some mild mauling.
I always thought that I was pretty good at handling my emotions.
But I think, actually...
Then people were like, you wear your emotions on your sleeve.
And I was like, I do?
And...
Then I was like, well I guess I wouldn't be a ghost if I...
If I was good with my emotions.
I just won one of your...
Shikishi!
No, I virulent!
Oh my god!
Oh, I was wondering when those were...
It's okay, I've waited too long.
My time was gonna be all off.
I was wondering when they were gonna give those away.
Oh, come on!
I barely tapped it!
Yeah, congrats virulent, congrats!
I barely tapped it.
There we go, that's what I wanted to do before.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Alright, alright.
Okay, I need to just burst.
No laggy, no laggy, no laggy.
Just, just, just burst, just burst.
Oh, what's wrong with me?
Maybe, just kidding, maybe I can...
I was doing so well that round!
I was doing so well!
I jumped further than I anticipated.
Will it feel good to win?
I don't know anymore.
What is it?
What does feeling good feel like anymore?
Oh shit!
Evil Mint, no!
Because you guys say that you don't like me anymore.
Oh my god, how did I make it?
I pressed it!
I did it!
I did!
I pressed the dog button!
I pressed the dog...
I pressed the dog button.
Oh, shit.
All I can see is...
This is the perfect one to end on, huh?
Because it's so green and it's St. Paddy's Day.
You guys are wearing green because you're like, yeah, I like Minto when she's green.
Oh, shit.
I keep fucking dying to the stupid spikes.
I need to do the thing.
Is there a reason you're not lasering?
It's because I run out of laser.
I'm trying to get him with the... I said it earlier.
I'm trying to get him with like the...
That power-up.
But...
Clearly I'm just really shitty at games.
And then it twists, so it doesn't matter anyway.
Like that.
That's the ideal...
formation.
Oh, please.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, why did I do that?
At this rate...
I think I would be able to speedrun this if I were any good.
At this rate... How many times have I done this damn level?
I
didn't have enough boost.
I didn't have enough boost!
Oh,
god.
I'm so tired.
Please put me out of my misery!
I've done this so many... I've played these games!
Oops.
Not before.
I've played these games before!
I almost...
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
You can't catch me.
I'm the gingerbread man!
I almost did not...
make that.
We're back.
Why did you do that?
Why?
I also think this one wouldn't be so bad if it didn't feel...
so damn long!
Even though I don't think it's even that long.
It just feels so long.
It's long for no checkpoints.
They were like, challenge level's real.
Come on, why am I doing different from before?
I feel like I'm going at the same pace.
It shouldn't get me with the spikes.
Or maybe I'm faster.
I don't know.
Am
I too fast?
Am I too fast?
For the level?
I'm too good?
I got too good at doing it and then I got too fast.
And now I can't...
I don't know what speed I was at though.
Because I was going as fast as I could before.
And now I'm going as fast as I can now.
So I don't know where the middle ground becomes.
I need to pay attention.
The re-chat on my cute tiny monitor is so perfect.
It was definitely a great investment.
Oh shit.
Wow, it can do that apparently.
I'm learning all sorts of new things about this game.
Knocked out of the park.
Home run, baby!
It's hard to watch Yoshi get thrusted and busted for three hours straight.
I lost the timing.
My chat froze.
Hold on.
F5.
There we go.
This
game is so evil sometimes.
This game is so evil sometimes!
Sometimes!
Wait, it just disappeared.
Hold on.
OK, I got you.
My hands are so sweaty.
I don't remember.
Oh yeah, there was the bing bong bing.
With the giant bing bell.
And then that was the end.
Yeah, I was so close to the end before.
That's right, I remember.
OK.
Position yourself.
Alright.
I think it's in my depth perception acting up again.
This game is killer for my depth perception, honestly.
OK.
Please.
OK, thank goodness.
That was so close.
Alright.
Yes!
Somehow I made it.
I think it's just a big hitbox.
I think so too.
I wonder if having the dog on my back adds to it.
Because I definitely hit the button there.
He just didn't thrust fast enough.
I'm so nervous.
OK, next one.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
There's another one?
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
I'm so sweaty.
I can't wait to take a shower after this.
Holy cow.
Hold on, I need a sippy.
Yeah, pray to Astro Snake.
Alright, we just got these three guys left.
I'm going to mess it up somehow, I know it.
OK.
They can't reach here.
But just in case, I'm going to stand on the corner because I'm scared.
Hi Astro Bot, please stop waving at me and turn around.
Thank you.
Can you turn around?
Then as soon as I get to the second platform...
The bigger guy is going to wake up.
So I have to be careful.
Sorry, I'm just seeing how... I wonder if I can run to the edge.
OK.
Next one.
Sorry,
I can't reach out right now.
I'm sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the super chat!
I can't read it right now though.
I really gotta concentrate.
I don't know how I lived.
I forgot he flipped upside down.
I was too concentrated on staying alive from the...
Shit.
OK.
We got this.
Maybe.
I can't say that or else I die.
Please.
That's... No.
That's actually evil.
What?
I was there!
That's so evil.
There was no way I could avoid that.
The game is cheating!
We made it.
Game is cheating.
Why did it do that to me?
Guys, don't talk about keeping a timer.
It's not motivating at all.
Anyone
who was here earlier, I went and did some other levels.
So maybe you saw that.
Or you saw me do it.
And then I went and did some other levels.
And then...
Oops.
I ran right into the log.
I wasn't trying to dunk on you.
It's OK.
It's a hard level.
And I have been on it for a long time.
Because I'm bad at games.
I think I'm just coping myself too.
I'm like, I did other levels you guys.
Don't you know?
I haven't been on this the entire...
What?
I think if I saw the world record for this, I might throw up.
I feel like I need to speedrun this part.
Actually, this level isn't even that fast... or fast... that long.
I think it's just got so much... I don't know.
I have no idea what makes this level feel longer than the rest.
I don't know.
I don't think it's so much longer than the others.
It is longer?
It is?
You think so?
OK.
Astro Bot is still having fun.
That's all that matters, right?
He's like, woohoo!
It doesn't matter how many times I die!
I'm not the one who gets to suffer for it!
So I know what's happening.
It's thinking that I'm reaching...
The third platform.
So...
OK.
So this is the middle.
And these are the platforms.
Right?
And it's like...
OK.
I go from here and I...
And then the thing comes and I...
And then you're supposed to go to the one with the...
This is the platform with the bounce.
It's thinking I'm landing here and it's spawning another thing.
But like...
The game is bad!
Because... Why would you have... Why would you...
Make the threshold like here?
I'm gonna reset the timer on these guys.
I don't wanna do what I did before.
I wish I could've...
Do the... I wish I could do what I originally did when I first got past that because...
I only had to go...
Against the two of them.
But...
When I accidentally messed it up before...
It was on accident so I don't even know what I did...
To get past all of those guys.
I feel like I'm valid here.
Everybody who's saying I'm coping, you're going to wrong.
I think I'm valid here.
No enemy should spawn where you...
Where you spawn.
Oh shit.
There we go.
I think I'm valid here.
You can make fun of all my other shortcomings.
And how bad I am at everything else.
Trust me, I already know.
See?
Why is it doing it now though?
It never did it before!
I don't think it's on a timer.
Because otherwise it would keep spawning like right here.
I
don't think... Game is bad.
That part is really poorly designed.
That part is so poorly designed.
Turn around, Astro Bot.
Turn around.
Turn your little body around.
There we go.
Oh shit.
I don't want to play anymore.
But I know I'll feel worse if I stop now.
I'll be even more frustrated if I stop now.
I'm suffering.
This dog is suffering through so much abuse.
So am I, so...
Abuse from the game.
Abuse from my child.
I forgot about the dog.
He's right there!
How could you forget about him?
See?
Why?
Why didn't it do it this time?
I don't understand!
The game is... This part is so poorly programmed!
Okay.
I want to see if maybe I can get them a little bit more out of sync.
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
I can't even make it to the part that I'm most afraid of.
You know what?
It's fine.
Goodbye slime.
You get to live another day!
Lucky you, huh?
Lucky you!
You get to live another day!
Oh shit.
There we go.
Holy moly.
I'm waiting.
Oh my gosh, I have to keep wiping off my hands.
It's nonsensical to me.
Okay.
Back to where we were.
Too much ectoplasm!
Thank you!
Okay, yeah.
Mom's spaghetti.
I wish I had some spaghetti.
Okay, alright.
Sorry, I'm getting nervous again.
I'm also watching the platform and how much he twists and turns.
Oh no, they're starting to get back in sync!
One down!
Okay, the big guy can't reach here just yet.
Yeah, he can't reach here just yet.
Yeah, I remember the tipping.
The tipping, I remember.
I just don't know how to...
Sorry, I know I'm taking so much time.
And I'm so scared!
What's the depth perception?
It's really bad with the bells.
Okay, next one.
Okay, we're good!
I saved it!
Alright,
that thing switches quite often.
It flips over.
Quite often.
I'm scared!
Wait for it to shake before you go.
Maybe...
Okay, go when it starts shaking.
But I'm so worried about this.
I can't pay attention.
Get me out of here.
I completed all five.
What the...
Thank
you, Fortnite.
Thank you, Fortnite.
You did it.
I did it.
Great thrusting.
Thank you.
Before we quit...
Wasn't there an area I forgot to do?
Was it here?
Hold on.
What's the map?
Never mind.
No, never mind.
I did it.
It's just this one last one.
You know what?
Now that I'm all warmed up, let's go give it one little go.
Let's give it one go and see how we do.
No, I didn't do all the secret levels.
It's fine.
I don't need to be a completionist.
It's alright.
It's fine.
Thank you, Ducky.
I got a message.
I want your Touhou Shikishi too.
What?
You guys are too lucky.
Congratulations!
No, no, no.
I'm not going to try to complete this.
It's OK if I fail.
Yeah.
We're in the credits now of the game.
Climbing all the people.
But I'm all warmed up now, no?
I might be pretty good at this.
Oh shit, never mind.
How did I do that?
I might be better at this than I thought.
Oh wait, I need to... Never mind.
I give up.
I give up!
Oh, now you don't want to fall off the edge.
Oh, but sometimes when I do this in the other level, you would just be like, oh I'm going to fall.
Oh no, now you don't want to fall off the edge, huh?
Is it scary Astro Bot?
Is it scary?
Wow, it's so pretty.
The shapes are talking to me.
I might be better at this than I thought, guys.
Classic Minto.
Classic Minto tactic.
Classic Minto confidence and death tactic.
I have to time this one, but I don't remember how.
There we go.
Can I jump through here?
Yeah!
Oh, I'm dead.
OK, I give up.
I give up.
I'm tired.
Leave!
No hotdog!
Oh, thank you for a hotdog Raichu.
Looking for a spooky dino.
That was all you Minto could give me.
Thank you!
And here, we are in space.
Space.
Are all my guys still there?
No, they left me here.
They left me here to die!
They said you'll never come back Astro Bot.
Thank you guys!
We did the secret...
Not secret, sorry.
We did the extra levels and I...
I'm done with Astro Bot.
That's it.
I'm good now.
I've done all that I wanted to do.
I've collected all that...
Honestly, I could have stopped at all the metal gears, but we did more.
Toad bust, but she can thrust.
I have a little bit there.
Nice fight though.
We thrusted and busted till we finished baby!
And that's the stream!
Otsuminto everybody!
Thank you so much for watching!
Thanks for hanging out with me!
I'll see you guys when I see you next!
Otsuminto byebye!
Byebye!